as you know i like to do some bible talk
at the end of the week but
there is somebody who is now joining me
on the line who is doing it
much more thoroughly than i am these
days that of course is father mike
schmitz
he is host of the bible in a year with
father mike schmitz it is the number one
podcast on apple podcast for 17
consecutive
days which was kind of a shock for folks
because what in the world was a bible
show doing
at the very top of the charts father
schmitz thanks so much for joining the
show i really appreciate it
absolutely it is an honor to talk to you
so first of all why don't you tell me
uh what kind of got you started on doing
a podcast
on the bible obviously it's it's
something that a lot of people are
interested in
uh i talk about it a fair bit on the
show but not like you're doing it in a
continuous and thoroughgoing fashion
what got you the idea to actually go
ahead and do this
you know that's a good question uh one
of the things i noticed is that um
i i love audiobooks i love podcasts i
love you
just listening to like i'll be making a
meal and just or going for a walk
driving and i'm listening to something
on youtube
and so i take in a lot of information
you know audibly
and uh i found that i fall asleep i sit
down to read
and it's like i'm out like a light um
but also i noticed something else so
one was the fact that like yeah it's
much easier to listen to something than
is to sit down and read it okay that's
one thing the second thing i noticed is
that man with a lot of
uh a lot of the stuff like say the news
and whatnot stuff going on in our
culture and politics i found myself
being so distracted by voices and so
distressed by like
kind of the stuff going on that i
thought you know i need to go back to
the bible
you need to go back to god's word and
just like allow my lens to be shaped
that way
um not just by really smart people not
just by um
uh people who have a lot of good things
to say and there are a lot of people
have a lot of good things to say
but by actually what's the story like
what's the big story so
i had that kind of combination in my
head of just like be able to listen
to god's word and then allow that to
shape my my my
world view allow that to shape my lens
and i thought it'd be really great if we
could just
how about once a day i have that chance
of like 20 minutes
and just let my mind let my heart let
the way i look at the world be shaped
uh not just by the world but by god's
word so were you surprised by the
outpouring of support
because certainly again most of the top
podcasts are news related many are
entertainment related but
this is the first one that i'd ever seen
that was bible related at the top of the
charts
absolutely it was one of those things
where if someone had asked me
hey father mike uh what is your best
idea
that you think would get to the you know
top of the apple podcast charts
i would not say it's me reading the
bible um
but i was it really reveals i think in
so many ways
that i wasn't alone in that sense of
being you know really just
constantly distracted and often
distressed by
um but what's out there and i think it
just really touched a nerve and a lot of
people
of course it's the beginning of the year
and people want to you know they want to
do something they know is good for them
um and i think that's one of the things
that this podcast makes easy it makes um
something
people know is already good for me makes
it really accessible it like reduces
any kind of obstacle to begin just press
play and you're in
well one of the things that's really
nice about the podcast and again the
podcast is the bible in a year with
father mike schmitz
uh one of the things that's really nice
is that it takes the bible really
seriously
textually uh which of course is great
because there are so many people who
only remember the bible from that
brief period of time when they were
children and they went sunday school and
they got the really kind of dumbed down
uh the sort of g-rated version of the
bible without any of the complexity
without any of the difficulty and that
that's something that you don't do here
you get in sort of the complexity and
difficulty of the bible
well and that's the thing too that i
think is necessary for us to understand
is that these are not the bible's not a
hallmark story right it's not
kind of really clean and neat um it is
not it's a it's messy and it's about
life
and but it's also about god being inves
involved in our lives um in a dramatic
way and i think that when
just like you said when we have this
cleaned up you know children's
vision of the bible and of what life is
supposed to be like
then it doesn't then the bible doesn't
measure up but then when we actually say
no
here's the messiness of the stories
here's the reality of these stories
and here's the true reality of the
presence of god in these stories
then all of a sudden i can realize so my
story is not very different than these
stories and i think that that's the
feedback i've gotten over this past
month has been people who
you know good people they thought they
were you know they thought they knew the
bible
like wow i didn't know all these stories
like i didn't realize the depth to which
um uh there's brokenness in the human
condition and even
in the chosen people you know the family
of god that god
enters into you know so abraham isaac
and jacob and following
but encouraged by that not distract not
um
not discouraged by that but really
really encouraged by the fact that
god chose these people and he worked
with them
he can still work in my life we'll get
some more with father schmitz in just
one moment first let me just remind you
tax date is coming up it is going
uh tax day is always bad unless you have
somebody helping you out now as we all
know last
year the government printed trillions of
bucks those dollars did make it into
your pocket via stimulus and
unemployment payments and ppp loans they
didn't tell you that's all taxable
and that complicates your tax situation
luckily for you there is tax
file tax file is a fully online network
of cpas and irs enrolled agents the pros
at tax file will do all the work for you
and save you the most money again tax
day is coming up march 15 for small
business
april 15th for individuals you need to
get ready you need to get prepared
tax file can help you you can connect
with a licensed professional in seconds
tax file has 3 300 cpas and eas all
licensed by either their state boards of
accountancy or the irs and
tax file is more affordable than h r
block and local tax shops they had a 100
u.s based workforce start today download
the tax file app or
visit taxfile.com use codeben20 at
checkout to receive 20 bucks off
that's tax file t-a-x-f-y-l-e dot com
slash ben your tax are going to suck
this year
don't make them suck more than they need
to use the folks over at tax file they
can help you out tax file dot com slash
ben
so much of the opposition to organize
religion these days is rooted in
basic questions that religion
answers but but has always provided sort
of interesting answers too
so the question that you always get from
folks who are not religious is okay why
would god allow bad things to happen and
it's though
this is a light that has never dawned on
anyone ever before
there are so many people who again went
to sunday school when they were 8 9 ten
years old and when somebody they go to
college and somebody says yeah well then
why do bad things happen to good people
and it's as though they've been hit with
a brick and the reality is that
you know that the question of theodicy
has been a little bit considered
by by religious thinkers since like
literally the very beginning of the
bible
uh the bible is spoiled with stories of
bad things happening to good people it's
filled with stories of good things
happening to bad people it's filled with
stories of bad people doing good things
and
good people doing bad things like the
shaded nature of the human condition is
not hidden in the bible it's something i
think you really get into
and that's something i'm so glad you
brought that up because twofold one is
uh in the first month one of the things
we do is we not only
follow genesis we also follow job so
like right away i think on day five
we jump into job and again the feedback
from people is
like i've known the story of job but i
did not know like the depth to which
uh job dives into that incredible
question and
again it doesn't dismiss it and i think
that's one of the things as you're as
you're highlighting
is there can be a certain degree of
post-modern biblical scholarship
that will try to it will do away with
those difficult passages it'll do with
with difficult stories
and not only that but you mentioned the
bible's full of people good people doing
bad things and bad people doing good
things
and it goes to the heart of the
complexity of us especially in our
current culture where like no if you're
a good person you only do good things
you've only tweeted good things you've
only said good things
if you're a bad person everything you
are is bad and i think
um in that way the bible once again
reminds us of
there is a bigger world and there is
more complexity to the world
and also more goodness in each person
than i think we're willing to admit
so father mike it seems like we're
living in a time generally speaking the
stats show this
avoiding religion increasing secularism
uh a movement generally away from
biblical living and biblical values and
the insertion
of secular values is sort of
pseudo-replacement a lot of anger i
think has has come
out because of that i think there's a
god-shaped hole in the human heart and
it's being filled with a lot of really
nasty things
right now do you think that there's
going to be you know a a comeback here
for religion and how do we go about
making that happen
i think there has to be i think that um
there
once it's kind of like um secular
humanism right
at when when that began when the rise of
this you also have
the uh uh the great awakening and the
second great awakening in response to
these kinds of things
because there's a degree to which if
you're a thinking person
um you realize that secular humanism
doesn't really have
a leg to stand on ultimately on itself
it propose
it proposes these virtues they don't
have any basis
in um in a light in a world that doesn't
have god in which god doesn't exist
and the same kind of thing when it comes
to revealed religion so not just kind of
like
i'm spiritual but not religious like
that's wonderful i'm glad that you
recognize that you are not just a human
not just a
matter but also spirit that's really
good but at the same time
a lot of people that i know i work on a
college campus who say that they're
spiritual but not religious
like well okay what do you know about
god well i know that god is love
okay how do you know that like i know
that god is good or god is just or god
cares about me like
i believe all those things too but how
do you know that
and the reality is we only know that
because he's revealed that about himself
and in a very specific place in the
hebrew scriptures and christian
scriptures and
without that you would have no idea that
he even knew your name
that he cared about you that he was just
or that he was good
um and i think that when people really
really search
uh their minds not just their hearts but
really
do the heavy lifting of thinking about
where do my thoughts where do my
beliefs where do my opinions come from
um you have to find a source or else
you're gonna be
you know try to you're sawing off the
the limb you're you're sitting on
well the podcast is the bible in here
with father mike schmitz really excited
to see it at the top of the
podcast charts thanks so much for your
time i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the ben shapiro show if you did go ahead
and hit the subscribe button so you stay
up to date on all of our future content